so thanks to Lana analytics and Jared
for inviting me here
I actually attribute a lot of my being
here and thank you and my career path to
him so thanks thanks buddy
all right intro who the heck am I so my
name is URI I work at glossier it's a
four year old e-commerce beauty company
that emphasizes choice peer-to-peer
connections and facilitates glowy and
dewy skin and so basically our what
we're known for is a skin first makeup
second that's our mantra so you can
basically say that we're a full-stack
skin care company with some makeup
products on the side but it turns out
this is actually a really good metaphor
for our work as data scientists so we
have a lot of excitement about neural
networks lipstick and cheek color but
not so much missing data logging or
sunscreen so to think about it another
way we use hierarchical models and
random forests and a smoky eye on some
occasions but a smoky eye isn't really
appropriate for every occasion
so what really matters is the fact that
you're using eye cream as part of your
daily routine
so there are base factors that you need
to incorporate into your routines
whether it's skincare or your data
science work so my career basically I
started a Facebook I worked on the
marketing science team for about two
years running a lot of controlled
experiments with advertisers to measure
the effectiveness of Facebook as an
advertising medium and some creative
multivariate tests and then I moved over
to Hillary for America where I managed
the digital analytics team until I
didn't and then now I'm about six months
into
glossier and so something that we say in
the data science community a lot I found
in my short career in data science is
that about 1 to 5 percent of our work is
about creating models cross validating
model selection the sexy stuff and the
95 to 99 percent of the work is data
cleaning munging sourcing data and
that's not so much the stuff we get
excited about so it was actually great
to hear the talk before this about
scaling and growing a data science group
but let's talk about how to develop a
good culture as you develop that group
and grow it and I'm the only person who
uses are at my company so it's really
wonderful to be around all of you guys
and to nerd out about our so just
basically this talk is a reminder that
there are some foundational principles
that we all should talk a bit more about
share tips about and so hopefully this
this fosters communication about these
sorts of topics especially during the
the breakout sessions so there are four
things that I want to talk about to
categorize the 95 to 99 percent of the
work that we do into four admittedly
very broad categories first sourcing
data to hypothesis testing third
documentation and then the fourth is
sharing our work with our stakeholders
but it's a little more fun to use in our
code metaphor within those examples so
this is a simple boring function I often
use to count the amount of missing data
in my data sets a few questions that you
typically ask yourself when you're
working with a new data set is how much
missing data do I have do empty strings
count is there some context that I'm
missing around persistently missing data
that I might need to take into account
in terms of technical limitations or
their ad blockers
that are preventing me from getting the
context from my client site events is
there imbalance data but this is a
metaphor so metaphorically what I mean
by this is let's use an example I bet a
lot of us have experience working in
digital ad measurement where a lot of
there's a ton of data there impressions
clicks time stamps and for better or
worse a lot of the value of those
digital advertising campaigns are based
on whether it click occurred or not but
a question that we should ask ourselves
is does our key outcome actually
translate well to our independent
variable and so in this case is a click
what an advertiser actually wants to
measure and optimize for kind of know is
the thing that they want to measure is
the value of a customer lead is whether
a customer purchased or not really hard
to measure let alone attribute clicks
painfully easy to do both of those
things and so something which we should
be admitting to ourselves and owning up
to ourselves especially when we're
forming inferences off of our analyses
and also sharing it with our
stakeholders who will inevitably
translate our inferences to others is be
really careful about how that
translation is being done you can
probably see too many really bad
examples of that across the internet of
how badly data was translated into
inferences but it's not just about
translations it's just about it's also
about what dataset are you working with
so you should be skeptical also about
where your data set came from in this
past year
five-thirty wrote an article very honest
article about how they had an
inappropriate use of broadband data who
encouraged you to all read that and
sometimes increasingly the conversation
in these days is actually around the
opposite of missing data so I don't know
how many of you have heard of gdpr but
it's basically data privacy guidelines
there's one fan over there data privacy
guidelines that were introduced by the
European Commission these these sorts of
laws we as data scientists absolutely
have to be at the forefront of these
conversations we have to talk to the
lawyers we have to talk to our companies
about what the impact is gonna be on our
work and what the implications are for
our ability to serve our customers and
our stakeholders as well so a money tip
one be honest with yourselves and your
stakeholders in order to build your
political capital if you're using a
proxy for your ideal measurement outcome
be upfront with yourself and your
stakeholders and be careful of what you
say because I'm sure many of us have war
stories about how there were
mistranslations between what you were
trying to communicate and how that was
taking a step further by others and at
glossier admittedly we haven't totally
solved the problem but a few strides
that we've made is we actually now own
the tech specs for the events that
happen on our website so that's one
piece of success and for the most part
I've seen at other companies the tech
team owns that we have to own those
things so making strides so the next
thing I want to talk about is this
sequel statement or also a bad joke but
that's subjective so we I don't know how
your workflows are like but mine are
often write a buncha sequel and then
write a bunch of are so the metaphor
being that there's a lot of pre-work
that we have to do before we do the work
so it goes to say the four before
beginning hypothesis testing we have to
think about the business question we
have to think about the theory so we
have to define our expectations ahead of
time and before answering questions
which are often
causal we have to ground those in theory
this sounds really simple but it's hard
to do in practice with a lot of pressure
especially from demanding stakeholders
and especially with these days big data
being promoted as a panacea our
stakeholders and sometimes us care a
little bit less about the theory
sometimes but we should Google big data
hubris and you'll find a lot of really
bad examples of how that was taken too
far and so some practical advice here is
actually from one of my favorite TV
shows Silicon Valley
so before often the main developer
characters actually talked about how to
tackle a problem they go to the
whiteboard they they think about the
problem they they lay out their
expectations they draw diagrams often to
hilarious effect and I feel like we
should do that too
so before so if a stakeholder comes to
you and asks you a question like does
this correlate with this thing back them
up get them to the business question and
I want them to expect us to not
immediately go to a sequel table or our
bi instance and start pulling things
around
we should they should expect us to look
outside the window or start drawing
things or doing like beautiful mind
stuff so let's encourage that from them
in any case I want us all to be beta
better theoretical data practitioners
and first stakeholders to expect that
from us so money tip 2 to start with pen
and paper get stakeholders to ask you
their business questions not data
questions it's your responsibility to
translate those into data questions a
great example earlier this week I saw
Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg on The Late Show with Stephen
Colbert and
he randomly asked her whether a hot dog
was a sandwich she turned it back around
on him and she asked him define a
sandwich what is the sandwich to you and
then they want to make the foregone
conclusion that a hot dog of course is a
sandwich so side note here some people
don't agree with me so I note here is
that something else I'd like to lay down
before actually beginning my work is
commenting so before I start and really
dive into an analysis I'll write a bunch
of comments laying out the the plan for
my analysis first load the data set then
check for missing data blah blah blah
and something I really like about that
is that encourages me to not get bogged
down into a data rabbit hole
I'm sure that's a very familiar problem
for many of us and then it keeps you
focused on your North Star so next thing
[Music]
documentation so speaking of comments
documentation this is obviously a very
bad comment duh you say I am reading in
a dataset you are right this is a bad
comment what I should have said was give
some context around the data set note
some quarks maybe a link to the github
sequel so comments are favors to our
future selves we this is something that
we have to do not just for ourselves but
also for obviously reproducibility or
sharing our datasets with colleagues who
might then go on to use our own code if
you're changing assumptions especially
with regards to cleaning your data set
it's easier to debug it's easy to
identify where you made that assumption
it's a friendly step up for other our
literate colleagues who
are moving your code if you're lucky
enough to have our literate colleagues
but I don't just mean literally I mean
metaphorically so we all know that there
is a replication crisis going on in the
scientific community right now
peat hacking so-called no promotion of
negative results big data obviously is a
problem in terms of wanting to make
datasets public certainly doesn't make
it easier to do that but there are a few
things that that we've instituted a
quasi that helped us be responsible to
our future selves and our colleagues and
our future colleagues too so we've
established a framework for sharing our
work it's sort of a five-part template
for how we share our work first a
mechanism for open commentary and
feedback we use a lot of tools at
glossier but Google Drive is probably my
favorite we have an executive summary
details about the methodology and why we
chose that caveat section is really
important and then also in appendix
where we can share our links to sequel
github contextual visualizations and
it's really hard to do this at a
fast-moving startup glossier just closed
on over 50 million Series C funding
round so people have very high
expectations of us rightly so and it's
hard to step back and and move slowly
and document all of our experiments and
our analyses but in the long run this
this ultimately becomes that much more
worth it especially when you're scaling
a team and when you're scaling a company
who can quickly grow into silos so we
need the the purpose of doing these the
this sort of framework whenever you're
executing an analysis it just helps
everybody else run that much faster
so money tip 3
be selfish to your future selves write
good comments document your work and be
open to critical feedback it makes your
work that much better and something that
we do a glossier is before introducing
our analysis or the outcome of an
experiment with a broader group with the
broader company we share with a smaller
group of stakeholders with trusted
stakeholders who we know are really
critical so next the last thing of
course I had a GE fot reference in here
I loved the power of a good simple
visualization
it's a metaphor for the strategy step
where we take in before we share our
work and we contextualize it for our
audience this can be the hardest part of
our work because we're dealing with
things like the dunning-kruger effect
politics again demanding stakeholders
who who have misconceptions or very
baked preconceptions in mind
so if you want to be effective if you
want your analysis and your work to go
far and have the biggest impact you need
to think about your audience and where
they're coming from and how to present
to them so I like to game theory it a
little bit and there there's some really
interesting research science research
out there about how you how you can
communicate with those types of people
so I encourage you to to find that
yourself but going back to the previous
thing that I said it's if this all
starts with a critical feedback period
where you're gaining different
perspectives about how people might
interpret your results and taking those
into account and doing that all
beforehand before you share that more
widely and obviously that helps you
better incorporate different
perspectives and be really critical
about yourself and expect and and grow
that within your culture of encouraging
critical feedback so money tip for game
theory your results sharing process take
your stakeholders preconception
slash misconceptions into mind
diplomatic please steer them towards
what you're trying to actually
communicate them and it ends up in the
long run
building more trust building more
political capital which I think we need
in the community these days and don't
bury the lead be upfront about what
you're trying to say be upfront about
your inferences tap on a great simple
visualization on top of it and that
helps you get your work that much
farther and that's it so I hope this
this provides some fodder for good good
conversation during the breakout talk
and I'd love to hear your tips about how
you guys share your work with your
stakeholders and how you document and
how you also balance the the trouble
between taking a lot of time to document
your work and share your work and moving
quickly
[Applause]